I'm an ER nurse and I treated a patient
who thought he could fly and this is
that story I was working in one of the
busiest emergency rooms in downtown LA
running around treating my patients when
we had a young boy rushed in from a
nearby University and he was admitted
for a traumatic brain injury he finished
his first year of medical school and he
was throwing a party the first year of
medical school is definitely one of the
hardest so it was just natural for him
to celebrate his achievement
he drank alcohol and he took two 100
milligram pills of MDMA just also known
as ecstasy mixing the alcohol with the
ecstasy can heighten the effect of the
ecstasy and also increase the time of
effect in the ER we do see a lot of
patients abuse ecstasy and other
Hallucigenia I think a lot of nurses and
doctors because they see the effects of
it they don't try it
they don't go near it ecstasy can
sometimes make you believe that you see
or hear things that are not actually
there and he believed that he could fly
so without hesitation he jumped off a 74
balcony his friends thought he was
joking initially when they found out he
was being serious and he had actually
taken max to see an alcohol together it
was too late to stop him from falling
luckily he broke his fall by hitting a
tree while he was coming down if that
tree wasn't there I mean he could have
instantly died the tree reduced the
force of which his head hit the concrete
he was unconscious and he had obvious
signs of traumatic brain injury
irregular breathing there was clear
fluid that comes out of the nose and
ears which is cerebrospinal fluid also
he had a lot of pressure built up in his
brain it can cause permanent brain
damage if it's not treated promptly this
one cause seizure strokes and even
sometimes death in the ER everyone has
to act really fast especially when we
get a trauma case everyone has to be on
top of him maybe several nurses come to
one patient
and putting in IVs one nurses putting in
an IV one nurses securing the airway
making sure the patient's breathing
everything happens pretty fast and they
are almost just like you see in the
Hollywood movies the family of our
patient is also our patient obviously
this was a younger patient so his
parents were traumatized especially his
mother who was initially had heard what
happened and thankfully they were in LA
at the time and she came in and she was
just crying hysterically and I was the
first person who saw her and just I held
her hand and told her that you know we
were taking care of the situation we
were doing as much as we can all the
nurses and doctors were doing as much as
they can to stabilize her son her only
Son and hopefully save his life
well usually when an coma is induced
it's because the brain is working so
hard to take care of the trauma so when
that happens the brain starts to swell
up and it's pushing on the skull and it
can cause permanent damage so in order
to stop the brain from working so much a
doctor will go in and use medication to
induce coma
sometimes when patients come off a coma
not only are they affected by the
initial trauma to the brain but they're
affected by the coma and the medications
that they were given some patients get
out of a coma and there they stay in a
vegetative state or v/s is what we call
it or sometimes in a minimally conscious
state where they can respond to stimuli
but they're not doing anything else so
the patient was in induced coma for two
weeks
finally and thankfully he his pressure
in the brain decreased and his vital
signs returned to normal so to my
surprise when the patient awoke he
didn't have any changes in his
personality his mood he didn't lose any
memory he was very lucky so all the
doctors and nurses worked really hard to
get him to where he was at the end of
his day he did come back several months
later to thank all the nurses that we're
still working there all the doctors
which was nice he brought a box of
doughnuts he was young and he had a
near-death experience which I'm sure
changed his life forever and the way he
looks at life and the way he treats his
patient because he's gonna be a doctor
one day especially as a trauma nurse I
do take pride in taking care of every
patient even if they just come in for
having a bad trip on ecstasy
you know just even if it's a
psychological help because we do do that
a lot in the ER as psychologically
helped patients get better it's still
taking me time to kind of shut off my
brain after I go home from the ER or the
ICU and not think about the things that
I saw that day sometimes just going home
and talking to my sister about it
it was also a health care professional
talking to a friend or anything and just
kind of letting it go and you just let
it go hard
[Music]